my name is Heather d Michelle and I'm
the director of sudsy created and I the
writer the music
the website it's not that's a TI SI TI
the film rights to talk about what a
social stereotypes Kentucky where it up
burn themselves and their husbands
beautiful fire and in contemporary
Indian volunteer taking the traditional
cultural idea and turning it around a
bit of an action in a thriller what
reward
we got together on a project called the
real girls guide to everything else
which I directed and in and it's it's on
the web real guys guide to everything
else there's real girls calm I'm sorry
but in today's episode web series that's
one of the bunch of awards done really
well and screamed in all the shorts last
erection
together we never quit you want to
abandon the project how does believe it
going
it's tricky
hands
today
it's been a great right
some days our collaboration is always
been hard at the beginning alert of
writing phase and once you get that
locked it's like with shoes let's make
it happen let's do it so once you get to
there there's no real